satisfait pas ses clés alors persie
wesley le frère de ron dans harry potter
que de souvenirs l'acteur chris rankin
était à l'armoire geek pour une séance
de dédicaces un moment privilégié que
les fans de la première heure ont saisi
ça m'a fait plaisir c'est c'est vraiment
j'avais la larme à l'oeil tellement dans
le film bel ami j'aime trop il est
vraiment bien il était décontractée
c'était très bizarre c'était la première
fois que je voyais un acteur qu'on
reconnaît dans la rue en fête est un
acteur de harry potter et il a été très
gentil
c'était un peu stressant mais un moment
unique pour les aficionados ainsi que
pour l'acteur qui ne connaissait pas
versailles pour chris rankin rencontrer
des fans est toujours un grand moment
onesphore msn spurs
c'est merveilleux c'est étrange et que
ça lui survivra longtemps je veux dire
ça fait dix-sept enfin saison que le
premier film est sorti ça fait toujours
bizarre que les gens viennent me voir je
peux comprendre pourquoi ils veulent
rencontrer percy weasley c'est important
pour les fans d'harry potter mais c'est
toujours c'est toujours étrange c'est
adorable l'amour qu'il nous donne car
harry potter signifie beaucoup
après la séance de dédicaces plusieurs
activités ont été mises en place pour
les fans dont un jeu de piste avec une
carte du maraudeur de versailles